oh mein gott wie wurde so oft in den
kommentaren geschrieben luca bitte
reagiert auf die neue hilfe folge in der
kürze liegt die würze ben und sein
kleiner johannes natürlich nicht nein
wenn der damen und herren ich meine hilf
mir ist eine absolute lieblingsserie die
spiele nazis in einer us-serie schulden
sich gegenseitig geld klauen
bevor wir jetzt hier in diese folge
reinschauen würde ich sagen lesen wir
uns erstmal die video beschreibung durch
und zwar steht dort die meisten frauen
würden ben 18 nicht von der bettkante
stoßen denn der angehende koch ist ein
echter hingucker trotzdem steht sein
erstes mal noch aus weil es da ein
buchstäblich klitzekleines problem gibt
seinen penis
vn ist der festen überzeugung dass die
frauen sich über ihn lustig machen
sobald sie ihn nackt sehen deshalb hat
er angst vor nähe sogar freundinnen
lennart 17 die er unsterblich verliebt
es letztendlich dran
ja freunde schauen wir uns das einfach
mal an
die folge geht 5 sekunden und sie will
ihm schon an die wäsche hier dass ich
hier ist sein gutes recht
der ben will nicht in der öffentlichkeit
sex haben ist sein gutes recht das zu
sagen
[Musik]
schwache leistung wird ja wieder an das
forschen haben
also man muss mal ganz kurz ersten auf
diesen einstieg klarkommen es geht nicht
los mit irgendeiner vorgeschichte wer
denn überhaupt ist oder wer seine
freundin ist oder so sondern die beiden
werden einfach in einer öffentlichen
umkleide gefilmt müssen wir in einer
öffentlichen toilette wie sie sex haben
wollen bzw
die 16 der ben will ja nicht dann läuft
wenn nach draußen und dort warten
irgendwie zehn leute die ihn alle
einfach auslaufen
hey ich finde lang einfach supergeil und
ich bin noch so verknallt denn sie aber
ich kann einfach kein sex mit ihr haben
einen mindestens einfach viel zu klein
sie
beide wirklich scheiße haben das ist
jetzt eigentlich mit hier und wenn
ich meine wirklich so schnell gekommen
wie alle anderen sagen dass wir ja noch
schön weil dann würde es ja heißen muss
ja ich wirklich so heißt das dass nicht
mal mehr halten kann aber stattdessen
hat er sich einfach cup ist und habe
mich sitzen lassen ich komme auf diese
komplette situation bisher gar nicht
klar diese lana hier beschwert sich
darüber dass ihr freund sie hat sitzen
lassen ich meine das ist ihr gutes recht
wenn die irgendwie bei ihr zu hause
werden und sich getroffen haben und ein
date hatten und wenn die zusammen sind
jetzt hätte rapid aber die hinter einer
öffentlichen toilette am helllichten tag
gewesen wahrscheinlich in der schule
was ist mit dieser laune los und ja sehr
in meiner ehre gekränkt ich meine story
das kann ich gar nicht weißt du denn für
einige heftiges opfer
das ist doch unfassbar das ist ja der
krieg an kompletten kotzan fall ich
dachte wirklich zu beginn dieser folge
dass bender jetzt das opfer sag ich mal
in dieser folge ist über den man sich da
mehr oder weniger lustig macht aber die
person als natürlich nicht über den
schauspieler dahinter so ich habe
überhaupt nichts gegen die schauspieler
sage ich ja immer das geht hier wirklich
für mich nur um die gespielten personen
hier und dieser lana ist echt komplette
vollbracht hat sich einfach vermisst
eine lange reise lässt sich nicht
zweimal von einem mann zurückweisen
lasst euch das gesagt
sein eine lange reise lässt sich nicht
zweimal zurückweisen
das hat auch von goethe kommen können
[Musik]
erst hilfen
einfach mal den
sie gab
das ist ja wirklich
ich weiß nicht ob es wirklich schulen
gibt an denen sage ich mal so abläuft
aber wenn irgendjemand aus dem ausland
das sehen sollte der wird sich auch
denken in deutschland alter was sind das
für vollidioten an den schulen das ist
schauspielerisch wieder zig auf in vivo
eines u-boots deswegen hast du leider
sitzen lassen
wenn timo das trumm zeit bin ich
geliefert sorry aber was ist dieser timo
den fünf fixer macht ein foto von seinem
und will das jetzt auch noch rum zeigen
ich meine was ist falsch mit ihm will
der bestimmt sich dass sein kollege
bleibt damit gerne ich mit der lange weg
den das lange kommt hierher und wir
wahrscheinlich geschlafen jedem handy
wird zu sagen er gema bitte ich hab
heute abend ein date ich möchte dass das
perfekt kommt und so aber der bodensatz
seinem kumpel der soll da bleiben damit
ein alibi hat wird er mit der planer
nicht schlafen muss leute aber wir
erinnern uns an die aussage die lahn
die letztlich zwar zurückhaltend es kann
nur spannend werden ich habe sehr sehr
champion ist ja und wenn sie dich liebt
dann wird das kein problem sein
ja du redest du einfach 116 watt ich
meine erste große liebe wollen mit dem
erstes mal anhalten dann gesehen hatten
sofort schluss gemacht alles erzählt was
er hatte mit 16 angeblich seine erste
große liebe was war das bitte für ein
mädchen jetzt schluss gemacht weil sie
einen penis ein bisschen kleiner war und
hat das war einmal erzählt dicker was
hast du dir deine frau ausgesucht aus
dem kommt auf die größe ankommt doch die
techniker das wird schon mal schauen was
die lena jetzt sagt wenn die vorbei
kommt okay sie kommt an
wow
der typ hier sagt darauf antwortet die
lana selbstverständlich und dann
antwortet der typ auf die frage gut
danke wie geht es dir denn wahnsinn
er ist weder schauspielerische 1a das
wäre so wie wenn ich sagen würde er juli
kann es mir was vom markt mitbringen
jahr 12 uhr ja keiner kann nur hoffen
dass sascha irgendetwas gutes jetzt
einfällt und er ist diese situation raus
bringt es ist nun wirklich diesmal eine
ganz ganz komische folge die wir uns
hier zu gemüte führen
ist es nicht so dass man sich wer die
leute lustig macht die dort mitspielen
sondern diesmal ist es mehr so ist man
wirklich mitfiebert sehr schöner blick
hier übrigens gerade ich bin wirklich
gespannt wie das ganze jetzt weitergeht
so erstmal anstoßen jeweils trinken
[Musik]
super wie er getrunken hat
angewandt später kam das ist okay das
ist jetzt entscheidende szene weil
entweder wird dem werden noch was
einfallen oder diese sieht dem
egal wir schauen weiter okay sie holt
jetzt hier wird ein kondom raus geht
jetzt angerufen
selbstverständlich weg ich kann das auch
noch im gehirn fährt ist das wichtig
der gare du gehst nicht beim sex
telefon besagt auch nicht während des
sex auf einmal auf fax hat den müll
runterbringen jetzt muss die
wahrscheinlich schnell weg genau jetzt
steht die schon mal auf jetzt stellten
sich hin
wie bitte wie bitte wie sie kann mich
sprechen was ist denn passiert
mutter von der umgebracht meine mutter
hat gerade ein ort für das war die
polizei ich muss sofort dass kein haus
sie kann nicht reden sie schwänze lässt
ich bin jetzt den mitbewohner von ihm
die mutter eingefahren hatte der
absolute wahnsinn wieder was ist jetzt
mit deiner mama ist wieder bei
bewusstsein meiner mama geht es gut
da hat sie einfach nur dann spaß alle ob
das stimmt alles gar nicht so
was soll ich dachte jetzt der typ hätte
wirklich hat er doch nicht weißt du ich
hätte fast fast meine er wo man stolz
wieder hergestellt naja du weißt ich
wurde noch nie von der bettkante
gestoßen und fahren nicht von selber in
die band
es habe auch nicht das schönste das
weißt du ja die lahder war einfach zu
ihrer freundin dass sie ihren freund
eigentlich gar nicht schön verrückt wenn
seine art ist ja schon irgendwie
interessant das musste zugeben aber was
festes
ich glaube nicht also mal ganz kurz noch
mal in dem text zur beschreibung der
folge steht sogar freundin lara und
jetzt will sie nichts festes
ihr seid doch schon in was fest du sagst
ständig irgendwie du magst du keine
ahnung stieß daraufhin auf mein freund
plötzlich ist doch dein freund
lana was ist los bei dir das zu etwa
jemanden beauftragt er sich für die
polizei ausgeht um mich anzurufen damit
ich schlafe ich sollte jemanden
beauftragt haben
er hat sich da in ganz schöne scheiße
geritten rede lieber noch mal wo ist sie
was sie ist das ist in der ausbildungs
küche aber wartet suchst du hast ein
wenig zahnpasta im gesicht
zwei stunden später im wellnessbad ideen
einfach eine karte setzen davon die
folge ist fast vorbei ich will jetzt
wissen ob da noch was passiert man das
so viel zu eng für zwei ja das ist
definitiv viel zu eng für zwei da drin
nicht so wegschubsen was ist denn ein
problem man ein dass es das liegt nicht
an dir das ist man ich habe angst
der bereitet sich immer mehr in die
scheiße ich meine sie hat bis jetzt
immer ganz cool reagiert wenn ich über
meine angebliche krankheiten was erzählt
habe und warum sollte sie dann anders
reagieren werde ich erzähle dass ich
angst haben mit ihr zu schlafen weil ich
den penis haben
euer ernst
ist vorbei
ich war voll gespannt alter an der
stelle würde ich meine reaktion auf die
bands kleiner biemann folge hier jetzt
auch beenden meine damen und herren bzw
ich muss es ja beenden weil die folge
vorbei ist soll ich vielleicht in der
woche oder zwei wochen wenn der zweite
teil von dieser episode hilft mir
rauskommen soll ich darauf auch
reagieren das gern leichter wenn ich das
machen soll schreibt mir gerne in die
kommentare
was sie auch noch mal reagieren sollen
und
[Musik]